the german government has shifted its
policy on ukraine and announced it will
deliver anti-aircraft tanks to the
country this says the united states
hosts a meeting of military leaders at
its air base in ramstein germany today
u.s defense secretary lloyd austin
called the gathering of ministers and
military leaders from some 40 countries
many of them outside of nato to increase
the flow of weaponry to ukraine beyond
the tank shipments germany has also
authorized the training of ukrainian
soldiers to use ultra artillery systems
on german soil in conjunction with the
american military
and let's hear some of what u.s defense
chief austin said at the start of the
meeting
and we're here to help ukraine win the
fight against russia's unjust invasion
and to build up ukraine's defenses for
tomorrow's challenge
as you know i came here after traveling
to keith
with my friend secretary of state
lincoln
we had a warm and candid
and productive discussion with president
zielinski and his team
about the support that we're providing
and the capabilities that ukraine needs
and ukraine's changing requirements as
the battle shifts
to the donbass into the south
now that visit only underscored my sense
of urgency
an urgency that i know that we all share
so i like this whole group today to
leave with a common
and transparent understanding of
ukraine's
near-term security requirements
because we're going to keep moving
heaven and earth
so that we can meet them
and that meeting is still underway and
close to the media for more i am joined
now by dw political correspondent
benjamin alvarez who is near ramstein
air base benjamin the u.s secretary of
defense is promising to move heaven and
earth there to support ukraine what else
stood out for you in the statement
that's right and he put the emphasis not
only on helping ukraine win this war he
said that ukraine believes that um that
the us believes that ukraine will win
this war ukraine believes that as well
and so does everyone else here referring
to this delegation that is taking a part
in this meeting he put the emphasis not
only on helping ukraine win this war
but also on the long-term security
assistance that all the us and his
allies want to keep providing he said we
will help ukraine win this fight and
build up ukraine's defenses for
tomorrow's challenges referring to what
he spoke to with ukrainian president
zelinski when the u.s
both ministers so anthony blinken and mr
austin visited the ukrainian capital a
few days ago
so 40 different nations are invited to
take part in this conference how
significant is that
it is highly significant because they
want to find a common approach with
their allies and as you mentioned
already this is not a meeting under the
nato umbrella that's what the pentagon
spokesperson said as well last week but
as nato secretary general jens
stoltenberg is taking place as well as
finland as well as sweden of course it
will have wide-ranging consequences what
will be decided here today
with of course the germany of course
making headlines already by announcing
this delivery of um of tanks of this
special thanks to ukraine tanks that are
not used anymore by the bundesverse or
this gap attacks that are very
specialized also anti-aircraft systems
something that is a huge paradigm shift
for germany but for the us for ukraine
and for its allies it's long overdue so
it will be an interesting day today they
will give a press conference afterwards
to announce how they will keep
supporting ukraine to defend itself
against the russian aggression benjamin
alvarez near ramstein air base thank you
so much
[Applause]
let's now keep talking about this
announcement from the german government
and bring in thomas biegel he's a
journalist specializing in international
defense and security policy welcome mr
vigod tell us more about these
anti-aircraft tanks that germany will
now send to ukraine how much of a
difference can they make in the war you
think
actually they can make quite a
difference it's not tanks technically
speaking it's short-range air defense
systems well it's an armored chassis but
still the main important point is a
anti-aircraft cannon on those
machines
and the german army
has taken them out of use almost a
decade ago not because they were
obsolete but because at that time the
bundeswehr was scaling down
and they had no use for it anymore i
think they regretted it meanwhile
because short outrage air defense is
much in demand everywhere now and
especially in ukraine so the ukrainians
can make use of it of course definitely
but this will also depend on how long it
will take to train ukrainians on those
gephardt
anti-aircraft cannons they are
not not really sophisticated by today's
standards but they require a lot of
training for the radar for the
electronics and so on
yeah that was one of the reasons why
germany was putting off um giving these
kinds of um this kind of equipment to
ukraine wasn't it
give us an idea of how well equipped
ukraine's armies now because there are a
lot of countries pitching in the u.s
secretary of defense said today he's
convinced that ukraine can actually win
this war
well he has to say this and
this a
psychology working at this point as well
if you look at the armament ukraine has
received from the west so far
this is more or less a light armament
it's
anti-tank guided ammunition german
panzerfaust it's stinger
anti-aircraft systems but light
anti-aircraft systems what ukraine is
lacking is heavy systems main battle
tanks air defense not only those light
air defense but heavier systems and this
is start to flow in mostly those old
soviet block weapons
from the czech republic from slovakia
probably from slovenia as well this will
go only so far because there's a limited
amount of these old soviet equipment
available in those countries who were in
the eastern bloc and now are part of
nato so if nato not nato but if the west
wants to continue
supporting ukraine they have to think
about starting training ukrainians on
western systems to deliver western
systems as well
now the german government was very
hesitant when it came to delivering
heavy weapons to ukraine that garnered
olaf shots a lot of criticism here and
abroad how big of a u-turn is today's
decision
well it's it's a u-turn it's it's a new
quality however uh it's again a decision
which allows the government
to to a
convey the the
idea it's not venue because it's not a
german stock it's not coming from the
german armed forces it's coming for the
industry so technically the german
government is only approving the german
industry selling those gay parts to
ukraine which is completely different
from the german army delivering
equipment
that's journalist thomas vika thank you
so much for those very interesting
insights
you're welcome
you